alligator sitting in light kitchen a
huge one Clearwater Florida resident
Mary with Juicin got quite the wake-up
call around 3:30 Friday morning an
11-foot alligator broke into her home
through a low kitchen window
the first 9-1-1 call came in just
minutes earlier when Patricia pakora a
newspaper delivery driver spotted the
perp when it was still outside the home
when I approached further closer he was
already then laying in the walkway by
the front door the unwanted visitor
spent an hour inside the house before
being taken out by trappers during the
apprehension the alligator knocked over
a wine shelf and suffered minor cuts
from the broken glass no other injuries
were reported in 2018 over 8,000
alligators were removed from Florida
homes I would not want to be waking up
and opening my door to seeing that
creature I me because he was very very
huge I've seen some big bugs in floors
I've never seen that thankfully people
jump by the cockroach that was in your
kitchen